well joining us now from her home in
derbyshire is lindsay jackson of the
covid19 bereave families fall justice
campaign group lindsay's mom sylvia
jackson died of covert 19 in april 2020.
lindsay good evening to you i know
you've just seen that video how did it
make you feel when you saw it
disgusted
wha what what did you think when you
heard that this video had had been
released and and that these are the
words that for example allegra set and
said stratton said quite clearly that
there was no social distancing involved
and you of course
couldn't be with your loved ones
the
i'm i'm angry on so many levels
i can't really begin to to gather my
thoughts adequately
the fact that this party took place is
bad enough
the fact when everyone else was
following the rules and behaving
properly and not seeing loved ones
that's bad enough
the fact that mr johnson's staff
clearly felt able to laugh about it
joke about it
find ways to
dismiss it in their upcoming press
conference
is doubling down on that awfulness
the fact that they're still lying
about the fact that this party took
place
is compounding the awfulness
i can't begin to tell you how
the
160 000 families who have been bereaved
by this virus
are feeling right now when we see the
contempt
with which our loved ones lives and our
lives
are treated by this government
it's despicable
despicable
well lindsay i can see you're very upset
and thank you so much for speaking to us
about this tonight to convey how upset
you are
um
what what do you think should happen now
given that you've now seen this video we
know
uh the prime minister denied it what
would you like to see happen
i would like to see
what we've been asking for from the very
start
which is a review
a judicial review of how the government
has managed this crisis
because decisions have been made from
the start as we saw when the parliament
did its own review recently
mistakes have been made all the way
through
this clearly wasn't a mistake
what this press conference is talking
about is a deliberate flouting of the
rules because people in downing street
think the rules don't apply to them
they think the rules are for the little
people
like me and my family do you feel the
prime minister
and his team represent you right now
given what you've just seen
well they represent the british people
because
the majority of the people who voted
voted them in i hope for goodness sake
those people are reconsidering their
votes now for the next election because
i do not trust this government an inch
look at this you hear from their own
mouths they set the rules for the
british people
and within hours they're breaking them
themselves the rules don't apply to them
well i'm sorry in a democratic civilized
country as this is
the rules and the laws apply to everyone
no one is above the law and boris
johnson needs to be taught a lesson that
the laws apply to him and his staff just
as much as they do to me
um we don't have much time left lindsay
but can you tell us briefly what you've
been through um with your mother with
sylvia and and
how that
contrasts with what we've seen in this
video tonight as you've just explained
it's hard to put into words my mother
was wonderful
and she was taken from me
before she needed to be
because of the mismanagement of this
public health crisis
and i will never
forgive boris johnson for that
have you spoken to other members of of
your group as you mentioned there are
160 000 families out there
have you spoken to any of them tonight
after seeing this video or hearing about
it
no not really there's a
a group of us on social media and people
have shared their thoughts and um
yes i suspect that my
reaction is pretty much mirrored by
an awful lot of those hundred and sixty
thousand families now
um lindsay jackson we're going to um
leave it there thanks very much indeed
i'm sorry to have upset you tonight
lindsay i can see how upset you are but
thank you so much for speaking to us
about what you're going through and if
there's anything else you would like to
say before i leave leave you lindsay is
there anything else you'd like to add to
this
you're welcome it is hurtful to
go through this again but if people
learn one thing it's
it's where your masks get vaccinated
and follow the rules unlike some of
these idiots that are in charge at the
moment
lindsey jackson thanks very much indeed